welcome to another episode of not too
deep I'm your host grace Helbig it's a
very thrilling episode we have not too
deep better enjoy Graceffa here with us
and also if not too deep new but Daniel
Preta
we talked about one their iconic digital
relationship and also exist in real life
we talk about secrets about escape the
night that I didn't even know existed
and we find out the pet peeves that they
have about each other it turns out
Daniels got a lot about Joey enjoy this
episode of not too deep with Joey be
sefa and Daniel prainha yay Joey Daniel
this is so fun
Joey your veteran over this podcast I'm
back thank you for coming back and
Daniel thank you first time thank you
for having me Terri's popped say
whatever we're going live they know can
you give me a little bit about the
journey to get here because you didn't
just come from your house you didn't
just come from a shoe you can would I
was gonna like go into detail my life I
was camping this weekend and Big Sur I
drove like five and a half hours
straight this morning left at 6:30 a.m.
or something and changed in a gas
station looking gorgeous did my makeup
while driving at 80 miles per hour on
the 405 no the things we do I mean one
I'm so appreciative thank you so much
for doing that with two that's some
extraordinarily impressive if you did
this in a gas station that feels like a
drag race challenge free gas but you
look fantastic thank you thank you for
being here okay you guys are the busiest
humans I've ever seen
so the fact that you're here is like
insane to me because you've been writing
books you've been working on shows
you've been working on crystals and
I hear a rumor the potential new YouTube
channel for someone yeah I'm gonna buy
it the time that just came out actually
yeah a few weeks ago that's so exciting
okay well I know you guys probably told
this story a thousand times so you can
give me like the abridged version what's
the origin story of this power couple
that's all him honestly I'm just the man
yeah you guys got together how did this
happen I stalked him on Instagram well I
don't know like you know like the Browse
feature this was like four years ago
okay so there was no messaging on
Instagram so I like somehow stumbled
across his page followed him realized
they couldn't like reach out to him or
like message oh yeah you just look at
him like a woman's publicly and I was
had his Twitter handle on there so then
I followed him on Twitter and since I
was verified he got the notification
like a normal person I'm like oh this is
a bot like he's like [ __ ] followers
or like you know following people to
unfollow or what did you know who he was
no no I didn't really know the YouTube
world I knew of a few people that I
watched you know the viral video is back
in the data are in college but I didn't
know it was like a whole thing yeah yeah
so I just I don't know I'm like at the
time I was interning at NBC I just
graduated school and moved to LA and I
I'm like we should get coffee sometime
and like have a business meeting alright
let's have like a casual date oh yeah
for coffee and see right so you can say
if it doesn't work out that it was just
a business meeting yeah yeah yeah and so
what happened um we didn't end up having
coffee we actually ended up both of our
best friends birthdays landed on the
same night and they were both out at
separate bars and I went home cuz like I
was done come on well I was a designated
driver that night so I wasn't really
drinking or anything okay and I invited
him out I'm like yeah just come to this
bar
no I was like no like I'm I'm tired
that's like scary I mean like you've
never met him and they're going to his
friend's birthday parties a choleric
thank you I was he was an extreme
introvert yeah my roommate Megan was
like come on just go like I'm fine
encouraging what they like but go out
have fun and just like just take a shot
and go so I took a shot and grabbed a
new burn met up with him and the rest is
history
yeah it was so scary because they like
walked into the bar alone and scariest
thing to me by the way like you overcame
a lot oh my god one of those things
where it was a bar that had two layers
to it so I mean front like party room
and then a backward like a doorway there
walk into the front part of the bar no
one's there there's no Daniel there I'm
like oh my god like have I been praying
yeah yeah
so then I went I was like I'm just gonna
go the bathroom and then I walked to the
bathroom and white oh there's a second
area never see him back there and his
cowboy boots and I was a boy I was
wearing pleather pants this was just for
real can we talk first of all I mean I
looked amazing party no oh it was just
like leather like I wanted a leather
pant with like a jean jacket I listen
apologize to me later I sold them at
whatever trading area later on sure yeah
I got my money but I lived a full life
what was your first impressions of each
other meeting in real life um what we
talked did we talk a lot before texting
we did because we're all traveling at
the same time so we texted for like a
month
no oh after we met we didn't go on a we
didn't go on another date for a while we
were texting for like a month so
basically like the time we were dating
we were just texting okay as he was
traveling to Spain or something we just
sat on the curb we actually didn't go in
the bar we sat on the curb West
Hollywood bar Lubitsch I love that place
yes yes right and we talked about life
and like what we want to do and like our
path like we share a lot of connections
like with our family and Oh craziest
thing we both found out that we are from
the same area awesome like rate outside
Boston right yeah oh you know like you
live like 40 minutes well did you have a
lot of like history that can cross over
that you can talk about my East Coast
love yeah well yeah we just talked for a
couple hours like what three hours so
far it was like a Lifetime movie and
that's what I wanted so I'm like that
when you guys write or removing is that
is that happening but now you guys are a
couple of the works together a lot and
also you know you're in a relationship
like where do you guys find that balance
of working professionally and then also
just like cohabitating it's been really
difficult you know when you surround
your entire life together I'd also like
to have a public relationship to like
that's there's so many different factors
that you have to think about yeah I
don't know how anybody does it but
somehow we've made it work and the over
the past year I took like a step back
from being as involved and working
together just cuz mm-hmm I realize like
I was kind of losing a part of myself
like I'd love to push him and I'd love
to help him and work with him but you
know he's so busy when your career is
going a hundred miles per hour like you
can't just stop for another person and
help yeah he's super supportive of me
and I'm grateful for that but sometimes
you have to do your own thing yeah yeah
you don't do what's best for the
relationship you know because I'm sure
it's really easy to be able to work
together cuz you guys are around each
other all the time but if it's nessuno
we both are very like stubborn anyways
like we both like just want kind of like
I did co-create together is there like a
safe word that you use when it's like
too much and one of you needs to like
take a step back
I'm not gonna do it that usually we find
like a something way that works yeah the
most part we agree on a lot of things
and we don't it's like we definitely
don't agree yeah
and he's such a nerd and like that I
love that about him and into sci-fi and
dystopian and like video games I'm
complete opposite I'm like traditional
like comedy-drama rom-com that sort of
thing so our minds work a lot
differently then but they can mesh well
together I can see on those two things
that seem opposite could work really
well together No okay tell me about the
house oh yeah you guys just moved into a
new place right yeah I've heard it's
been a journey oh my god the longest
journey of my damn life yeah it was hell
so basically we got into the process of
moving into this home almost like a year
and a half ago probably close to two
years okay and then the whole building
processors took forever and then
basically there was nine months of delay
and I had sold my house and basically we
were just living from Airbnb to Airbnb
and one suitcase
each like all of our stuff was in
storage the dogs like we couldn't find a
rental house that would take three
Huskies well yeah they had to go to
boarding one would come with us for a
week like would interchange I mean the
job doesn't go on high no yeah I'm
working out of home for that long of
time it was mostly frustrating because
the Builder was like oh it's just gonna
be like another couple weeks so we would
never like put in place like a living
situation more than two weeks because we
didn't want to overpay right right and
then obviously urban B's people rent out
certain dates so by the time we found
out that it was gonna be a longer stay
we had to like move somewhere else yeah
how to build a billion a house in LA to
rent on Airbnb forget about your it's
like exam yeah that gives me anxiety
just hearing about it so then what
happened um I mean we just had to keep
waiting it out tiling and B&B rental
like that whole hamster imagine that for
like a YouTube career too and he was
balancing the book show champ gaming
every was literally a day before I shot
season 3 of escape tonight we move
ow how to go straight to set to shoot
and we were expecting to move into the
new house rate after escape tonight yeah
it ended up being one the last episode
aired of escape tonight we finally moved
into we're here I lost the 10 pounds of
depression weight such an unstable
retirement constantly there's like no
routine nothing I mean there's already
no routine in the way that you guys live
your lives anyway but that added to it
yeah wizards any like horrible Airbnb
stories or any like I'm spiderus listen
spiders everywhere and these rentals and
I hate film I love an old house with
history so I'm like oh this is gorgeous
with totally yeah I love that and I can
live anywhere I can live like down on
the corner I can live in a hotel
I'm fine but he know if there's one
spider in sight he's out I'm not just
one spider that's true yeah it was the
spider den that's what had these long
trees like eucalyptus trees on the
outside and they would like nest so all
the baby actions would come and creep
into the house what do you do it's not
your house either you totally she got
like an external you got an exterminator
it didn't work thankfully we ended up
leaving those towards the end of Archer
like uh
how's the house now good makes me really
lazy because like I just like don't want
to see anyone don't want to make an
effort to see you know everyone like
comes to me right it's your safe space
and we moved really for the dogs because
we have a yard now there's three dogs
now yeah yeah and they all just like
lounge outside and play all day which is
like that's why it's a dream yeah that's
truly a dream what was the Husky
fascination was this that I love wolves
so much right okay and I think they're
the closest dogs that look like wolves
yeah so it started with wolf like the
name came first and then I got the dog
which he actually found in downtown I
was in downtown LA and this guy was just
selling a little like
size of a hamster he was so sickly
looking on the corner of like the
garment district it was like on the
street yeah that might be I'm like okay
so you're either stolen or I don't know
what what the story is here and I was
selling for like what $150 yeah was I'm
like that's a purebred I can tell he's a
big boy 90 pounds of so I'm like I
texted I took the cutest picture oh my
god which I'll send you and I sent Joey
I'm like you need this dog or we need
this dog or something I was like
thinking about getting a dog Oh cute and
like the moment that we went we went two
days later it was in the mill the night
this sketchy area downtown so wait you
didn't get the dog been in there you
went later you made plans so there's
like Street dogs that we go and it's so
super sketchy area and they're in the
front yard and they hand me the dog and
literally he just like nozzles in yeah
and then after that they just sort of
like showed up on our doorstep
basically just Huskies calm like you
know what's the game plan how many more
maybe one more but not anytime soon no
I'm not you can have an LA s3 oh yeah
yes I think Anna Akana
told me that the legal amount of cats
you can have is like five or six before
you basically but no we - was the magic
number then once we got the third it was
like all hell broke loose I really
ruined the dynamics between the two the
two are now picking on the first one and
she's a woman the first woman in our
home because the other two dogs are gay
yeah when you know you know see yeah
what it had how did the third one come
into play basically just showed up on
our doorstep
it was like a rescue situation
oh gosh you guys at home and we found
her oh that's very sweet
um you were talking before about escape
tonight which is I'm fascinated about
about this series how would you explain
it to someone that's never
heard of it before um it's I always say
that it's like clue me survivor okay
it's a bunch of people or I guess
youtubers thrown into the situation
where they have no idea what is
happening at all but they're interacting
with actors who do know the storyline so
it sounds like you're thrown into a
movie or video game and you're just kind
of acting as a character in the world as
yourself also as this persona that
you're given to kind of like put
yourself in this make-believe world okay
you're solving Clues you're escaping
rooms you're going up against each other
there's a death challenge every episode
so someone gets eliminated right um so
there's like a voting process that
happens where like the two random cards
will be chosen and um they have to go
into this battle and whoever survives
survives and Watford doesn't dies off
the show so it's it's a reality show
yeah it's big I like to call it that's
grace okay cuz that's my like most
confusing thing is like is this scripted
or are they really doing like a skate
broom challenges right no one like you I
ever youtubers that comes into it
they're like yeah I figure like we're
like told what happens in sup and
they're so shocked when they find out
like when someone that comes in with
like a crazy like killer is coming to
kill you I don't know any of the
creatures so they're just told the
reacting character but like as
themselves in this world yeah yeah it's
a heightened reality yeah yeah a like
fictional escape room yeah scenario oh
that's so interesting but it's the whole
world because we shoot night shoots
which you know are exhausting yeah we're
in the middle of nowhere like the props
and the art department is so amazing
shot so beautifully that's why it seems
like a fully scripted Siri I didn't want
it to look like a reality show I want to
fear factor yeah right I want to feel
like there was depth of field in the
cinematography and do they get to choose
their characters or they kind of written
out for them beforehand Oh like they
work with a writer to figure it out we
kind of look at the poison honestly the
archetypes are really just about the
outfit
and just kind of this styling on the
show is unbelievably well thank you yeah
so many awards every year it's great I
mean the aesthetic of it is fantastic
really really fun oh that's so that
brings like a whole new world to it to
makes I thought it was like scripted I
was like everyone's acting really well I
know I get that question all the time no
I get that comment all the times like oh
my god the youtubers are such bad actors
I'm like we're literally not acting or
just being herself
I thought everyone's doing a great job
I'm really impressed because I was a
little nervous that maybe this would be
a little crazy so I was like oh no
they're being like very natural this
what was the hardest thing about making
that series um the hardest part I think
it's honestly just the exhaustion yeah
because it's so much we shoot two
episodes and 1900 ch and the in between
the two episodes is just like our
downtime and that's like 2:00 a.m. and
that's when everyone's just exhausted
yeah so getting back into it for the
second episode like kicks in one like
someone's chasing you and like there's
clues to be solved right right right
well that makes sense - okay this now my
world is like all the doors are crashing
down so I'm like oh when like the clowns
are taking them away they're pretty
gentle and that really is now it so it
cuz it's real it's nothing acted then
that way
okay that's so fun okay we're gonna take
a quick break when we get back I have a
billion more questions for you guys if
you don't mind we'll be right back with
more nectar deep
to deep support for today's episode not
too deep comes from every lane never
overpay for quality clothes with every
lane they make premium essentials using
the finest materials without traditional
markups and they tell you their real
cost because they want you to know what
you're paying for and why in fact they
are radically transparent about
everything from their materials to the
ethical factories they work with em
since Eveline sells directly to you the
prices are 30 to 50 percent lower than
traditional retailers everyone's clothes
look better cost less and last longer
they have essentials like cotton crew
t-shirts they have a human box cut too
you know I love a good box cut they have
cashmere crews they have silk short
sleeve square shirts that I mean they've
basically anything high-rise skinny
jeans mid-rise jeans boyfriend jeans
heels everything you could possibly need
they have and it's super creamy quality
no frills just quality and right now you
can check out the personalized
collections that Jack and I have put
together of items that they have
actually sent to us right on their
website go to Everland comm slash Grace
and you'll get free shipping on your
first order that's ever Lane comm such
grace every Lane comm such grace we're
back yeah yes we're back okay you Joey
how long have you been on YouTube now 11
years 11 years and didn't know how long
would you consider yourself in the
social media world in the direct world
of Joseph I'd say four years okay maybe
a little less because you were oh we
were undercover dating for about a year
but you've been so understanding social
media so what is your relationships now
with social media I asked this of
everyone because mine right now is like
I'm you know figuring it out so for
someone that's been doing it forever
like and you still post so regularly you
still like work on all of these projects
you still do all this extraneous like
more traditional stuff like how do you
balance manage all that um very well
yeah hey join the club
no I feel like I'm in the same boat as
you I'm just like it's like the burn out
face right now I'm just like things are
changing a lot with YouTube yeah it's
kind of like a different world that I'm
not used to so it's the adjustment Paulo
city yeah yeah there's a lot of
negativity and there's a lot of um
bribery yeah and a lot of just like
excessiveness Mike celebrated in a way
that it seems like the like pure kind of
you being you doesn't yeah it's
exhausting which is an awful message I
think to give to kids who are you know
thrown this image of what a perfect
teenager looks like yeah regardless of
what you do or what you earn or what
you're enhancing to your body like I
could not imagine growing up in a time
like - 2018 had all of this and I was in
high school a goddamn best I think we
all grew up like seeing celebrities as
something that wasn't attainable there
was a line there there was like you need
to work your ass off for X amount of
years to get yeah exact same people come
up overnight like isn't same for me to
see I mean I feel insecure and just like
not enough and I have like somewhat
success like I can't imagine being a kid
in high school and like just being a kid
and like having to have those feelings
like if I'm feeling that then they must
be feeling it yeah and times worse like
it's crazy
yeah just seeing numbers and seeing like
this like very public what you could
call like measurements and judgments of
people I think yeah people are making
that super public now like when I saw
all of your friends like tweeting back
in the day like nobody was saying like
oh just hit 2.6 million tomorrow oh just
hit 2.7 million well did you not like
this video cuz it didn't hit a million
views in 24 hours like says calm down
yeah mortal eyes like I'll take um like
five views and like very encouraging
audience member I'd be really great
are there any with that said social
media people or channels that you guys
like obsessively follow for either
you guys both tilted your heads like
your dogs
no I find myself like because I started
record pre-recording for my channel and
yeah I thought I found myself like I was
trying to figure out an intro which I
still haven't figured out yeah but I was
like talking like him and using his
voice and like being overexpress I'm
like what you guys have like your own
language I feel like you develop this
like there's some term for it but when
you make a character out of things that
are just not a lot of kosis you guys and
I feel like it's just natural just speak
at these words that I'm like is that a
word
I so I feel like you guys had a real
heavy hand in this whole wig snatching
oh you guys have been saying wig I think
I was like eight months old when I first
you would say like whiggy whiggy whiggy
on unless or something like that there's
a whole wig you can really add it to any
word and it makes sense what's the
phrase now or word know everybody's
killing all the fun words like you and
your friends and oh yeah I have a lot of
weird words that I hope will become
trendy I can't really share them at this
time exactly but I don't know it's fun
just to be weird and be silly baby yeah
what how would you describe your channel
if people don't know about it already
right well it's mr. parada on YouTube
Twitter Instagram and that's about X is
G M is ter PR e da are you making like
cuz you have a really I don't know if
you keep up with it but your website
it's like a very cool like lifestyle
aesthetic thank you I did that when I
was in college and then as soon as like
Instagram Twitter and everything I still
do it occasionally but I got really
bored with writing because nobody reads
it anymore I get like oh it's all right
you know
like I'd rather watch a video and it was
really hard for me I'm really good in
person like I can speak to anyone and
then like when I start when Joey
introduced me to his audience like four
years ago three years ago it was really
hard for me to be myself because I just
didn't know how to act because I see so
many people put on like a persona right
the camera and I'm like okay so there's
like no course in learning how to
interact with a stranger that comes up
that knows everything about you right
and you know nothing about that yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's like Orson at dinner
who's like tapping for something and you
don't know how to react it's just a
little bit of everything right now it's
am I'm I'm passionate about all things
like home travel there'll be some point
decorate your guys's house like crazy
and this is gonna come out the day
before Christmas so like oh my god I'm
recording this you know early November
have you already they're already in the
bag not true it is yeah the tree goes up
tomorrow because everybody frowns upon
like January first I just take it down
so give me November December I'm like
there's a lot of worry Martha Stewart is
currently rolling in a ditch somewhere
because I've taken her holiday wig so
yeah come on by and hopefully I make you
laugh is there pressure every year on
yourself to up the decorations so now
we're in a new house this is the first
year the blueprints have been in my mind
so it's about a year ago yeah
construction of them I can't wait for
you guys to see oh my god I'm so excited
I think this is gonna be great yeah
they're um I don't I wouldn't I don't
want to spoil anything that might show
up on the channel it's okay um you guys
travel like crazy together and you do I
mean people must come up to you like
regularly what's the most memorable
funny fan interaction that you've had if
there's been one more embarrassing well
it's now Joey never leaves the house we
don't have this problem as much which is
nice but when you were touring or doing
anything like that
had some experiences in LA where my
windows down in my car and I'll be like
singing to a song and there was this one
time that this one of the Star Tours bus
which doesn't have like any enclosure so
my windows are down and like sings like
Selena Gomez like being super gay girl
in the van next to me like notices me
and I'm like like I wasn't singing I was
just like moving the mouth and then she
starts taking pictures of me and like
obviously no one else on the bus or like
older knew who I was but they're like oh
my god
she's taking pictures of him must be
like a big star or something so they're
all like looking at me taking pictures
that's also a Jif I wish that I could
see you just rolling up your windows I
don't have any of those stories but I do
have stories like every couple months
like whether I'm in an airport and
having once at the Melrose trading post
like it was just the right outfit the
right day right look I'll have people
come up to me like you're Ashton Kutcher
I love your work and I'm like I was
gonna you guys get mistaken when I was
younger it happened more yeah no no
because when I'm clean-shaven I turn it
out my I always say ask what am I gonna
shut are your dreams in front of yes
I'll take it you can figure it out later
horror story saying yes to being someone
shooting a music video back when I had
my email hair uh-huh on the beach are
you Tyler Oakley when we both we like
similar because of the hair so this two
little boys come out to me they're like
hey hey I'm like hi they're like oh are
you Anthony from Smosh and like because
I get that all the time I was with my
friend at the time too and he was like
yeah he is and I was like like I guess
I'm just gonna go with it yeah so
they're like can you do that um the shut
up from Smosh is there like intro and I
was like oh my god I was like no I don't
like to do that in person
coming up to me and asking me so then I
finally did it they're like so what's
the next shut up because each episode is
like a different like thing that goes
with it
how to keep going along with it it was
like a lie wish I never did I know those
kids still live with the fact that it
was really rude to us
that's incredible okay where's the best
place that you guys have vacation and
where you going to next because like
your instagrams are like Pinterest
dreams of vacation goals I like to go on
little mini trips like two nights
camping or something cuz he's not an
outdoor cat okay I always come back but
I like to stray away for a few gain
amazing things what's your favorite
thing honestly everything I love Kyoto
is the old capital of Japan a lot of
history there it's just so magical not a
great to it there too yeah but it's the
next place we want to go to New Zealand
New Zealand New Zealand yeah no that's
on my short list ooh I've never been
there's so much to do there it looks
insanely beautiful every photo gorgeous
yeah and I like I said before I love a
camping moment I love a tent
I love glamping oh it's gonna say I'm in
New York I do it I do everything but I
think the older you get like the less
you're gonna be on the ground like you
don't need you okay when you guys
writing a Broadway show a Broadway show
I feel like you've done everything you
could be the narrator that is true turn
my book into a Broadway show he listens
to the same five songs since I met him
like on Louie I'm one of those people
that so listens to my high school music
so like what's I mean just fell killing
it yeah okay I've been listening some
since I was in ninth grade so it's like
so cool the park that like
my favorite bands it's all good but it's
almost Italian EJ and I grew up like a
musical theater nerd so I was I my high
school had a small pool of men so I
always got the starring role in every
show so I felt like I'm like wow I am I
am Broadway why I haven't been starring
on anything like Chandra ok what's your
dream well okay so there's drama in high
school I dropped out of Bye Bye Birdie
so I would love to reprise my role as
Conrad so basically some closure on
exactly I I think it was like spring
vacation they wanted me to stay to do
audition and not others to do rehearsals
and I'm like no I'm going away like this
is the first time my family can afford a
vacation I'm going and I came back from
st. Maarten looking tan and gorgeous and
I found out that I kind of got fired but
then I quit that was your last show I
was a senior anyway so but I feel like
there's no you know how's the time your
YouTube channel get it going right like
might just do like a one-man show of
five I've already got no one okay let's
talk about eating yeah okay so the third
book has been out it's the final
installment hmm okay how did this come
about
because I know that you're like Daniel
was saying you love fantasy sci-fi you
love dystopia how did this must have
been like a dream to do then yeah I mean
I loved reading like just so peein
fantasy book since I was a kid so I
never thought that I would be able to
even create a book especially because I
grew up in special education classes
like I always felt like the dumb kid in
class so I never thought that I'd be
able to actually like create a book not
only a book but like a series yeah but I
did and I absolutely loved the process
yeah when you're passionate about
something yeah then and you link up with
the right people just who's the
co-author on it Laura Sullivan yeah how
did you link
with her basically I needed help on to
figure out how to actually like create a
story land in like I have like all the
ideas in my head but to actually put
them in like a proper way in a book she
was able to help me take my ideas and
put them in the correct order yeah
supposed to be in know it cuz it's the
idea of writing a fictional or like why
I like novel so intimidating to me that
you need someone that has the expertise
and knows how to make it feel like a
professional book ya just need that
remind set to like he'll go into his
office or if we're on vacation like
you'll disappear for like a long time
his mind is the way it works is amazing
like I don't know anybody as creative in
that world and yeah he brought it to
life in an amazing way it's weird how it
like comes to me like be it just typing
on my computer and it's like I see it as
a movie as I'm typing so I'm very visual
so I'm like already planning like the
movie in my head as I'm just like taking
oh yeah yeah I mean that's been the goal
since the beginning but it's so hard
because the world that I've created is
so expensive yeah a really huge world
that it's gonna require a huge budget
that it's ya know that makes it did you
are did you always know that was gonna
be three no I started with the first one
and I had more ideas that I was like I
can't finish this one so I knew the
second book but the third one didn't
really know exactly what I was going to
do but a king to me it was definitely
the most challenging out of the three to
write very cool and what's like the best
feedback that you've gotten from people
that are like loving this um I feel like
just people connecting with like the
plot points that I've created and like
them actually like getting what I was
trying to put across I'm just loving the
characters and like shipping the certain
characters and shipping is always a good
sign that means people are fully
invested in the characters and they want
to see more yeah okay whoo Dreamcast for
the
who would you cast himself I did write a
character in there that was kind of
based off me mm-hmm and that's like the
main characters brother
so that would be me okay want and
unknown to play my main character so
like an upcoming chorus and then I
really I love Emma Roberts
perfect character for her - it's like
this kind of the same character that she
plays in our story oh yeah I mean put it
out there thoughts or things manifest
that destiny okay let's talk about drag
race you guys have drag alter-egos yeah
I'm we don't know I'm here in drag now
oh yeah I saw the yeah okay I did want
to ask about Halloween's I saw the
photos you guys looked amazing what's
the process in planning Halloween
costumes this is not a last-minute throw
together oh it was Joey Joey every year
just wants to be gorgeous yeah murmee
yeah I was like I ordered a bunch of
random stuff off at see I was like well
whatever arrives like I ordered a peach
costume
I ordered stuff to be a witch and I got
one shell crown together and his costume
was so stunning I teased his hair before
he went out so he looked very well you
were what yeah that's also my alter ego
priestly in chief of north of runway
magazine you looked stunning one look
Austin I did I want I want a mixer a
KitchenAid mixer in matte black oh this
is from Rosanna oh no it's stunning I'll
never use it but it's a yeah and I just
love that character and it was very last
minute I just want to bring her to life
you saw you could see me at Macy's I was
trying on all sorts of women's clothes
cuz nobody makes
for a broad shoulder yeah savelii you
put this together all yourself yeah I
know I mean I wasn't a wig incredibly
well like a long wig he was just like
yeah it took me six hours I was watching
the movie I watched it three times
because I'm a character yeah and I don't
know how to stop but I'm like spraying
and clipping and trimming and I had a
buzzer and it's honestly exhausting
we're gonna take another quick break
when we go back now we have just Twitter
questions for you guys and these are
thirsty and fun troll this episode not
too deep is brought to you by class pass
it is a Fitness membership that gives
you access to over 10,000 studios and
gyms around the world you can try any
workout from bootcamp to Pilates to yoga
and more all booked able with one
easy-to-use app class pass takes the
barriers out of working out you don't
need to plan a circuit or do anything
just book a class and show up they hold
you accountable too so when you sign up
for a class with your friends you're
less likely to quit class Pass is more
than just working your muscles when you
try new kinds of workouts you increase
dopamine and boost memory formation and
they drive results when you work out
with a trainer you get more effective
workouts which will help you get fitter
or eight your goals faster they're
motivating because they're always
working out with the best trainers in
the biz it's a fun way to re-engage with
old hobbies like swimming and climbing
tennis and more Jack talks about class
pass all the time it's super convenient
and it gets you out of you know your
traditional comfort zone of ways that
you workout that might you might find
boring you know maybe you'll find a rock
climbing class you didn't know could be
interesting to you so check it out you
can get your free trial at class pass
calm slash try slash grace that's class
pass calm slash try slash grace
okay we're gonna get into some Twitter
questions before we do I'm gonna ask you
guys the two questions asked every
single guest that is on the podcast
the first is who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti at oh
I think honestly Donald Trump I have so
many names but I know I'm gonna be
ruined and canceled if I say any of them
so I'm just gonna go nameless and just
say anybody who is an ass online and
promotes negativity or isn't humble yeah
no I think that's a great answer yeah
two very politically wonderful answers
okay the other question asked every
single guest is to tell us your worst
pants [ __ ] story or close call but
you can only use three words or three
small phrases so mine is college jogging
front lawn in a shaking okay so three
words or like a small phrase you can
interchange eight years old in the
shower feel like you pressed it into the
drain no Hank green has introduced us on
a previous episode of not too deep to
what is called waffle stomp oh I
remember
I hardly ever remember things from
episodes afterwards but for whatever
reason that's burned into my brain
forgettable waffle stomp if you have a
situation in the show I mean what are
you gonna do pick it up mine would be
6th grade sleepover sleeping bag buried
in the backyard paints a very vivid
picture
actually I'm like respectful of you oh
it's still there and like they find it
one day I mean someone had to have found
it they'd just like it's like a ghost
story - who did this okay now we're
gonna get into some Twitter questions
great guys we got a billion first one so
Ricky Dillon I mean he wants to know
what's everyone's favorite Britney song
of course Ricky would ask that you got
in there Joey
toxic Oh God it's her best one well I'm
gonna be politically accurate for all my
Britney stands and say I can't pick a
favorite because all my favorite but I
will say 2002 is an amazing year and
anything from the golden era of pop 2002
to 2007 mmm okay thank yes that's all
income writing good for you I am a
classic I like oops I did it again yes I
just every year I consider wearing that
for Halloween you I don't think I can
they started selling it at Urban
Outfitters I realized somewhere I should
back off okay see I've been just waiting
to get my Victoria Secret body that's
the other thing too is like right be
nothing but self-conscious right right I
think I'm gonna do it next year though I
say that every year
okay um some of us know why don't you
guys like pet names and what are your
guys's pet peeves um I don't like pet
names
you don't like got names for each other
but you pet name literally everything
around right that's so true I don't know
it just makes me cringe fair maybe we're
not there yet maybe we'll never be there
okay okay but what are your pet peeves
doesn't to be about each other
I think it's just in general let's do
each other's pet peeves oh okay really
dramatic he hates my say no oh it's so
annoying say no like we'll be out
shopping like for French or whatever
he's like would you like that I'm like
no or like hi I have a great idea for
something no I am a person I know what I
like and I don't that I don't know
and I'm just very like quick with Lacey
I prefer hmm I prefer something else Oh
an explanation or considering it's just
like what about that one yeah an
alternative plan for me I could be here
probably all day it's mostly all
household things so he will open a
cabinet or several and leave them all
open I think it goes Oh leaves his socks
like tucked into them well I feel like
on the couch I get hot and I just slip
my socks off and you know like I just
forget to pick them up it makes me
scream and they find their way into the
crevices of the guy and that's just like
a hoard about it also she doesn't eat
fun like I wish I had somebody I could
yeah like adventurous either my good
like let's order pizza - yeah but large
cheese you didn't bed and watch a movie
yeah I'm just not into it you know you
know I mean that's I'm with you today
yeah
scandalous evening right like shame yeah
without the shame though like we'll be
leaning in to it thank you trash like
you'll catch me in a car at like
midnight in the driveway like eating it
Oh fine candy wrappers in the cow oh so
my socks might be repelled by the king
representing guys you never find the
pizza boxes do you okay speaking of food
who is the better cook or yes who cooks
what better everything I cook breakfast
oh yeah he doesn't make my office but
sometimes he forgets to make it for me
cuz it takes that's not true at all I'll
be like making myself breakfast I'm like
for like ten days in a row I'll ask him
do you want breakfast no the eleventh
day why do you pretend like I'm not
hungry at all yeah the mind games I
means a lot and I'll be like do you want
anything he'll say no I always still
order him some
either that's true that's sweet you guys
know what it's their secret language now
I know about breakfast yeah someone to
know when are we getting a YouTube
tell-all book spilling all the tea
Daniel oh never I'd be arrested somebody
would hire a hitman I know too much any
books for you I'm gonna take it one step
at a time yeah I feel like a book for me
I know a lot of people have written a
book but maybe my life's not as
interesting or I'm just mentally not
ready I need experience more because I'd
like to write about like the career your
name and everything but maybe in the
future the doors always open right you
know um okay well someone wants to know
what's Daniel filming oh well surprise
surprise
ISA ISA channel go check it out okay
someone to know whose YouTube channel
have you been watching a lot recently do
you guys watch YouTube
he only watches YouTube well not so much
you kind of come down recently I do I
didn't know yeah I'll go through like
binge phases of watching like a ton of
stuff and then realize like I've got to
step away and watch them yeah I like
fall into a hole of drama channels of
like the beauty drama channels oh it
makes me ill no I can't watch them it's
too much I don't like messes with your
head
yeah no I can see that be more dramatic
now you didn't blend that right Joey
talk about swatches a lot like you faked
your swatches you see that's hilarious
I mean so I would I think find the
comedy for the beauty people like they
get it no worse yeah I mean there's a
lot of like standards that they have to
cue up to like that industry is so and
everyone just wants to find something to
criticize them on I mean that's like the
Internet ow - yeah it's also tough like
you know you're in the beauty industry
you're in an industry of judgment by
nature because you're trying to make
yourself more beautiful to everyone to
live up to whatever standards so I think
it's just inherent that people are
judging each other constantly and then
when you realize that
that sort of Garner's more attention yes
it's what works and what kind of like
the drama like sparks interest and like
sells products or whatever so I feel
like a lot of it is maneuvered and
situational like I think people start it
on purpose
sometimes yeah I don't trust anything
like after watching tons of reality
television programs like I don't trust
an organic site that's happening this
isn't gonna be a big reveal to a launch
of something at the end of the day I
think you guys have done a really good
job of steering clear of you know being
in that sort of realm of you have a very
positive vibe to you guys which I
appreciate it's what happens when you
don't have any friends but I also I was
camp I was camping recently and I wanted
to know how to move bomb so because I
was gonna stop in Santa Barbara get
tacos so I pull up Patricia video which
I watched hers occasionally yeah in
which I love yeah you wanted to learn
how yeah and I'm like oh like do you
need like a set schedule of what you're
talking about or do you just eat and she
literally set in a car in a 7-eleven
parking lot eats and just talked like
even takes long like 45 second breaks of
no talking no editing does not edit out
the awkward yeah it's so real so she's
the one to be right now my taste but she
does open the eating okay
favorite drag race season and Queens I
really enjoyed this last season oh yeah
season ten was one like I'm shocked you
weren't on the influences episode I was
actually on tour what happened okay six
so even if I wasn't untaught all I
probably wouldn't thought sick if I
wasn't on tour but yeah I was on tour I
couldn't do it yeah and I also was very
bitter about that because I was gonna
live vicariously through Joey because
that's my biggest dream I've been
watching since season one introduce you
to the show you're welcome
I know because we were at the same final
together I've never seen it live before
and they like just emailed me if I
wanted to go nothing absolutely yes I
want to go ma'am had never seen a single
episode of it at all my god she came in
completely blind and it was like a
shovel or like no I was so good so long
I was so but yeah I know eight hours and
that's all the Queen sit next to you and
they're just Fanning themselves so hard
and you realize like oh yeah because I
can't have air conditioning on my
makeups ready
and they all are kind of quietly shading
each other like one Queen will be on
stage and they're all like look I live
for those like a camera but my favorite
queen I think is Alaska oh yeah she's
fantastic
I fell in love I mean I've loved the
show since season one which I don't
think you can find anywhere on the
internet right now Edwards as well my
favorite season is season four okay I
think it really put it on the map with
like the drama and just because the
characters I didn't start watching it I
don't know what seed I started watching
seasons after it started and then like
fell off and then started watching only
like the last couple seasons um who was
in season four
it was Latrice Royale Willam Fifi O'Hara
yeah and Sharon Needles so it was like
originated the drama so if you're gonna
start drag race I'd start it for work
your way up and then go back and
appreciate season one two three if you
can find them favorite queen I'm sure
favorite Queen changes all the time it
does yeah I have some like true like
tried and true queens like Bianca Del
Rio
I love Latrese she's so funny I love a
lot of the newer Queens - I love detox
oh yeah yeah they're great have you guys
gone to dragged on yeah you did yeah I
did I worked I was interviewing a bunch
of Queens it was amazing but if I ever
do it again and I ever interview Queens
I want to be in full drag because I just
like what hey like I'm a part of the
party yeah otherwise it feels yeah like
it's just like look yeah looking at
people okay
someone to know how much okay how much
time earn how much how much money do you
make how important do you think is the
role of friendship in a romantic
relationship yeah I think for all of my
relationships like I had up a strong
friendship I think you kind of like
build romance on top of that I think
with you is a little different because
I've never like really fallen in love
with some of the second I met them
mm-hmm and then you learn to build the
friendship afterwards I would imagine
yeah but no he Joey is my best friend
other than my other eight best friends
no he me telling me a story about like
his best friend every single time it's a
different best friend you can only have
one best friend so which one okay I'm
gonna lay this dress for the last time
we can have more than one best friend
there were different parts of my life
where that person like came through and
they're still there but we don't talk as
much Joe I have like six best friends
but they're all like my squirrel friends
like I don't have a lot of knights of
the round table exactly what's your
favorite thing to do together I love to
travel I love to travel with Joey like
do you guys have a I mean you must have
like a Travel routine yes I like travel
with like you guys know how each other
travel like wild girls but also I know
how he travels and sometimes I'm like
listen you're not gonna like this trip
so you're gonna stay home and I'm gonna
go with one of my friends because we
have to be in the wilderness well that's
good and it works healthy boundaries
yeah I understand that yeah we do that
we I mean honestly we hang out we would
love to watch movies oh yeah you know
the sweet house set up now would you
like why would you ever yeah if it's
great the simple things we're not too
crazy like we don't go I love dancing
and I love to turn it out but not so
much anymore
I'm retired you're elderly yes okay
sixteen actually it's also no were there
any major screw-ups on escape the night
like breakdown sub characters or puzzles
not lurking or cameras getting in the
way oh my god puzzles don't work all the
time I know that this is like an actual
really like game scenario how do you
handle that I mean I know everything
that's going on behind the scenes but
none of the other people do like when
something doesn't go right um
they have no idea there was one incident
and this last season where we're
supposed to be breaking Roseanna and
Sofia out of this jail and me and Manny
are like we have this like crank that we
have to like bust the door open with um
and just like was it marking and Manny
just thought that we weren't doing it
right but I knew like it was just broken
it sounds like kind of like peeking over
to like production of my guys come on
know tannaz she was very interesting on
the show yeah there is a camera we're
not filming anymore it's like an
in-between the scenes and she sees a
blue post-it note on the ground she's
like oh my god guys I found a clue
sister that's just a post-it note like
the clues actually look like very like
there's also a lot of like
behind-the-scenes drama lo casting drama
it's very interesting to get to know
somebody's team or how they really are
oh I'm sure yeah it seems like you get a
very first-hand look at all this last
season was actually the most
professional and phenomenal cast like
very good just no complaints they were
all like very nice to have um exciting
but okay
so many people are asking about marriage
and children oh honey I know we've had
this conversation a couple of times and
it's just were just not we're honestly
we are still children I think also the
most mature thing to admit that right
like ironically maybe not even like the
way I act
oh no I'm definitely a child like the
world that we live in with social media
and also I don't need to do the same
thing that my parents did right and get
married that's so young and have kids by
the time they're 26 like that's not my
American dream anymore my dream is to
like be happy with the career I'm in and
the relationship in I'm in and then when
I'm ready to give my life up and die
then I'll have kids like when I can no
longer dream which I can't wait for okay
we're reaching the end of the podcast so
what's next for you guys what's going on
Daniel I know that your channel will
have launched by now it's a big venture
I'm excited for and I'm really nervous
for but that's good like a good thing
and you care about it how about you Joey
by this time I think my EP will be out
possibly my music video Kingdom yeah
that's the other thing too oh yeah
that's my that's gonna be out good we
can say that it's good oh there you go
you read it here it's kind of like a
sequel to don't wait in a way okay which
is the last music video I've done just
like 2015 yeah yeah so do you want to
sing now for us absolutely
thank you so this will be out by then
yeah oh that's so exciting
shipping the EPA what's it come Kingdom
Kingdom is the EP okay that's so
exciting
Congrats both of you thank you thank you
for making time before you go we're
gonna give you what we give every guest
on the podcast and you get it
personalized [ __ ] carb yeah yeah you
don't have to eat it it's more about the
message inside but you're welcome to if
you'd like I think you got the same
really good way to find clues you can
use it I mean they're the same I have a
more soothing voice you'll host a
gathering and someone will spill their
beer into one of your plants vases but
you won't even notice so honestly like
move on already get over it and yes I'm
sorry I'll pay for the replacement gosh
extraordinarily sassy business it's a
fortune for you oh yeah
whoever breaks one of my plants it has a
death wish you guys obviously haven't
checked out everything that they're
doing constantly please do well that's
an ASMR for you wait too deep deep deep
deep not too deep is a production of
grace helbig incorporated a producer and
directed by Jack Ferry producer and
editor
Melissa demons writing by Diane King
production assistants by Katrina Henning
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music